I like comma specifically because we're building
something that has never been built before;
so it's the, the new frontier. It's space
exploration. What's up? Oh yeah you're
good. Okay take three! [laughs] My previous
job I worked at a big company and if I saw
something that I wanted to give that specific team
feedback on, it was quite difficult to, to do so
just because how large the company was. With comma
if I want to tell somebody about something within
openpilot or some other aspect, I can walk down
to their office and just talk with them directly.
The two things that we look for, fundamentally,
are intelligence and motivation. You know, if
I'm thinking about a company I want to work for,
I want to work for a company full of great people,
right? You got to make sure the bar stays really
high; not just for who you hire, but also for who
you keep around. I think we have the best chance
at solving self-driving cars because our approach
involves actually shipping a product and
proving it out as we go. It also allows us to
become profitable and be, you know, financially
responsible. So we have thousands of users every
day that upload data and we process those
drives that they upload. Most of them within
seconds and all of them within like 10 minutes or
something like that. Everyone who has tackled the
self-driving car problem has done it, like, the
silly way where you try to like you know put boxes
around everything and then you take all those
boxes and try to like figure out you know what
the car ought to do with some hard-coded algorithm
and like I feel like the whole lesson that we all
have learned in the research community is that
you should just learn everything! You know, learn
it front to back and that's exactly what we do.
Just waiting for this [ __ ] to install [laughs]
You know, we, we have a whole stack that
teaches the car as closely as we can to
just do what a human would do; you know,
imitate the human driving policy and that's
like what what makes comma really
special in the self-driving space
is just that we're doing the smart thing
to teach cars to drive themselves. Um
no, no cone detectors here. No cone detectors...
that's how we do it. The people at comma
have a desire to work harder. I vibe off of that
and I feed off of that energy of others, like,
wanting to, like, just do everything they can.
And so that helps me kind of also want to work
harder. Self-driving is going to be solved by 20
people and, uh you know, a thousand computers.